wow people are fed up and those poor
poor flight attendants cheryl i go to
you first as a former flight attendant i
mean we have seen a lot of unruly
behavior this year and last
you know i saw this video on christmas
day when it began to circulate among
some of my former colleagues and they
all just waved their eyes and their
heads away just said you know what
not shocked at all but i want to point
out something here she is screaming over
this 80 year old man who good for him
gave it right back at her
but she didn't have a mask on either as
a former flight attendant my first
question was alcohol involved i think we
need to ask that question but the bigger
issue here is that this has become the
norm in the skies and it goes back to
what the faa and the airlines have done
really the faa and that's basically you
know take the hammer down on flyers the
two-year-olds that have to wear a mask
now the the rules the regulations people
are either drinking too much alcohol to
get on the plane to deal with the stress
or you've got people coming on board
that are just angry but unfortunately
this is this is now
the norm and this is the middle of all
the cancellations and the and the sick
outs that are because the flight
attendants and pilots that are getting
covered kaylee i will say to you really
quick i was so glad to read your tweet
that you had a good experience with your
daughter when you flew because i was a
little nervous about
how it was going to go for you and your
family it's just tough up there right
now
thank you cheryl i was so sorry the
flight attendants gave her wings they
were so nice and gracious sorry i have
to say that thank you flight attendants
no no of course but you know kaylee let
me bring you back in here because you
know
just last month 10 passengers were hit
with 225 thousand dollars in fines for
unruly behavior more than 51 000 reports
of unruly passengers this is a nightmare
kaylee and
a vaccine mandate could make it worse
listen to dr fauci
if you're talking about requiring
a vaccination to get on a plane
domestically
that is just another one of the
requirements that i think is reasonable
to consider when you make vaccination a
requirement that's another incentive to
get more people vaccinated if you want
to do that with domestic flights i think
that's something that seriously should
be considered
kaylee
yeah that that should never be
considered that is a ridiculous
statement from dr fauci but what this
boils down to there's been what 5 300
incidents maybe not all this bad this
year alone up from a few hundred
last year what we need here are to
cheryl's point an excellent point the
faa with these onerous regulations like
two-year-olds wearing masks that's part
of the problem but also show a little
grace if you have to wear a mask wear
the mask make the job easier for the
flight attendant and don't put a flight
attendant in this situation they're
doing their best they're working hard
we're all stressed because of covid show
a little grace to the flight attendants
to your fellow passengers it'll go a
long way and have calm airways we
already can't take the delays we can't
take brawls in the sky on top of that
i know mercedes we're at our wits end
here and i was thinking of this
potential vaccine mandate to get on an
airplane and you know i think of the air
quality and the filtration systems in
the airplanes it's pretty strong
and i i think of how omicron is
spreading in areas that have such high
vaccination rates so i i guess my
question to you mercedes is would it
really make a difference in keeping the
number of infections down
well first they should stop serving that
spiked eggnog it's just way too strong
on the airplanes okay but uh what we see
right now is uh you know look the words
wording that dr fauci is using right now
where he's saying that it should be a
requirement requirement meaning it
should be forced these vaccines right
but that would serve as an incentive
being forced and an incentive do not go
hand in hand and so we have to take into
account that many americans for one
reason or another they don't feel
comfortable getting this vaccine whether
it's a medical exemption religious
exemption and so they're anticipating
what is the supreme court going to do on
these vaccine mandates it's caused an
enormous amount of stress for these
forced vaccine mandates in private
companies in the health care industry
and i gotta tell you my motto for 2021
it's been the world has gone mad and we
have to get to a point that we allow
americans to make their own personal
choices instead of authoritarian
governments and private companies
telling you this is what you got to do
it's putting so much pressure on these
private companies so much pressure on
our workers as well as well
and then and then it blows up in the
instance on delta that we we showed
david when we came into this block a
passenger is just going at it and the
flight attendants
playing police officers and they don't
want they don't want to play that role
do you think and i know i'm asking you
to speculate a little bit here but we're
talking about the frustration of people
the frustration of flyers do you think
mental illness
had anything to do with that woman who
attacked that 80 year old man her state
well she certainly was under some type
of influence whether it was a mental
condition or an alcoholic or a
some drug related
influence we certainly are a
long way from the 1965
fly the friendly skies of united
airlines and as airline
have to cut back on flights because they
don't have enough employees you start
seeing the direct impact of why now you
have the cdc coming out and saying you
don't have to be quarantined for 10 days
you only have to be quarantined for five
days there starts becoming a practical
reality that if you want private sector
businesses or government employees to be
able to work you have to let them go to
their jobs